早速ですかと思いますけど
しかし まあそちらの説明はまあ今日はできませんしね
まあとにかく今日のテーマ
あの できるだけわかりやすくしようかなと思ってますけど
まああまりわかりやすくするほどの能力はないんです
ですから 皆さんはどうぞ頑張っていただかないと
この前 あの道徳っていうのはこの絶対的なものではないということはね
絶対的なものについては説明いたしました
能力と幸福をまあまあ含めすぎて
それまあ不道徳についてね
まあ不道徳ってどういうものかと
まあそれで心っていうのは不幸な悪循環に陥ってるということで
我々の心はまあ不幸になるような設定なんです
ただ待っていても幸せになるということはないんです
ですから この まあ悪くなるように
不幸になるように まあできているんです
では まあ話の内容に入ってみましょう
で 不道徳の特性 特徴 この不道徳っていうのは人間の心の家なんです
まあいわゆる我々はまあ不道徳
悪いことをすると随分あの自分の家にいるような落ち着くんです
で 趣味とも言えるんですよ
随分楽しくやっているといえば悪いことばっかりなんですね
で まあ道徳やろうとかボランティアしようとか
これかなり苦労させないとね
もう誰かにこの えーと
あの馬みたいにね あの口に何かつけて引っ張ってもらわないとやってくれないんです
しかし 悪いことになってくると
随分もう趣味やってるような感じで
もうやみつきになってやるんです
だからおもちゃなんですね
不道徳っていうのは人間のおもちゃです
人間の心の家なんです
それはよく覚えた方がいいんですよ
で まあやりやすいっていうことですね
悪いことだったらね やりやすいし
まあ随分楽しいんですよ
嘘でも言って人を騙したりすることなんかはえらい楽しいんです
だからやりやすい 落ち着く
良いことだったらいくら頑張っても
説明しても理解してくれない
取り上げられることは嫌がる
だから不道徳なことを
まあ倫理的でないものをね 「
やめなさい」と 「タバコ吸うなよ」と
そういうふうに まあ悪いことを取り上げられるとものすごく嫌がるんです
「嘘を言うなよ」とかね
あるいは嘘は言えないような状況の中にはめたりはめられたりすると
ものすごく嫌がるんです
不道徳について示されると
人の自由を奪われる話だと思う
だから真面目に頑張りましょうとか
嘘を言わない人間になりましょうとかね
人 自分のことばっかり考えないで
人のことも考えなさいというと
この人何言ってるんですかね
私の自由を奪って奪って奪おうとしているんではないか
私に邪魔しているんではないかというふうに思うんです
だからよく人は自由について語っているでしょうに
よく考えたことがありますか？人間考えてる自由って何なのかと
例えばアメリカは民主主義国家ではないんですけど
自由な国なんでしょ 何？何をするために自由ですかね
いかに悪いことをするのかって
それだけでしょ 自由なの
金さえあれば人殺しても何のことなくうまく逃げられます
陪審制度なんかあるんですけど
まあなんとかなんとかしてごまかすことはできます
だから自由自由と だからその自由は他の国々にも教えてあげるそうで
いうと このアメリカの文化
行く行く国に何が増えるのかというと
貧困と犯罪なんですね
豊かさはもうなかなか程遠いですけど
アメリカ文化を受けたフィリピンにしてみたらどうでしょうかと
まあ貧困やらもうあれなんです
どうしますか もう 誘拐とかね
キリがないんですよ まあイスラム文化っていうのをすごく嫌がるのはそういうわけで
自分たちが言うわけじゃないんですけど
まあそれが入っちゃうと困りますよと
まあどちらでもないなんですよ
やっぱりまあ結局私はこのアメリカ批判してるんじゃなくて
この自由というのは悪に自由と言ってるんですよ
悪を思い存分やらせてくださいと
だからこの 悪をやらせてくれないと自由がないと言うんです
例えば中国は麻薬使うと死刑に
恐ろしいという それを自由がないんだと
すごく批判するんです
そんなもんなんです それから幸福に成功に邪魔をしていると思う
で 私たちは道徳やら倫理やらを語るならば
相手が自分の幸福に邪魔しているのだ
せっかく儲かっているのに
詐欺やるなと言ったら何言うんでしょうかと
儲からなくないんではないかと
だから せっかく幸せで儲かって幸福にいるのに
この道徳倫理なんか出しても我々に邪魔している
と思うんですね ですから
教えてあげなくても 子供の頃から不道徳的な生き方には慣れているんです
だから心の家と言うんですよ
子供にあまり誰も悪いことを教えませんでしょ
でも隠れて何やってるんですかね
見事に知ってるんです
悪いことだったら 誰も教えてないんですよ
嘘言いなさいとかね 人のものだったら取り上げなさいとかね
喧嘩しろよと誰言うんですかね
でもやってるでしょ だから不道徳
悪っていうのは我々の心の家なんですよ
我々の趣味であって おもちゃなんですね
だから子供には趣味がないんですけど
おもちゃがあるでしょ
子供のおもちゃは不道徳なんです
[背景音楽]それはこの不道徳の特徴なんです
これは理解してもらわないと
もし異論があったら言ってください
私はこの意見には反対だよと
それはディスカッションできますけど
仏教的に見るとそういう世界なんです
で どうして皆様の心の中に異論起こるはずなんです
なぜならば 皆様もただご飯食って大きくなったわけじゃないでしょうに
いろんなものを勉強して
いろんなものを経験して
今まで大人になってきたんだからね
道徳に過ぎてご自分の考え方あると思います
必ずぶつかるはずなんですよ
こういう話は ですから
自分のご意見とぶつかったならば言ってください
はい 異論がないということで
人はだったら問題が起こるんですよ
皆様問題作らないんだから
私は問題作らなくちゃいけないんですね
なんて不道徳な方々かと
それ不道徳ですよ だって勉強する場合は色々異論立てたり
質問したりしないと自分のものにならないんです
黙って聞いてるということは
もうたった瞬間で全部忘れるということなんです
まあそれはそれで通りにいいんですけど
前の理屈から言うと 人間の心の家が不道徳であらなければ
人類はね 極悪人でしょう
でもそうではないんですね
極端に悪くはないでしょう
人間というのは あれって何でしょうかと
本来悪趣味であるなら
人は極端に悪人に悪人であるはずです
しかし そのような事実はありません
いわゆる極端な悪人というのは稀でしか現れませんね
好きなことだけして生きていると都合が悪くなるんですよ
それが理由なんですよ
わがまま本気で自分好きなことばっかりやっていると
どんどん都合が悪くなっちゃうんです
どういう風にというと
自分の期待が外れる いろんなことを期待してもうまくいかないんです
我が物好き勝手に生きているんだから
社会から認めてもらえない
社会からもう追い出すんですよ
これすごくきついんですよ
人間に何かグループというか
何かグループを作らないとなかなか生活できないんです
だからみんなそれなりに何人かの仲間を作って生活しているんです
だから家族も一つの社会なんです
社会から追い出すということは
日本社会から追い出されるっていうのではなくて
家族から追い出すことも社会から追い出されることなんですよ
それ決して楽しいことじゃないんです
そういうことで都合が悪いんですよ
それで良い人間になろうかなと思うんです
家から追い出されると
ちょっと街になってみようかなとかね
は思うんですよ だから
たったそれだけの理由で極悪極悪人っていうのはない
いない ほとんど 単純でしょう
考え方は 本当は我々はもう悪ことばっかりやって生活したいんだけど
そううまくいかないんですよ
例えば学校に入ったら
いたずらやら人をいじめることばっかりやりたい
やりたい できればもう最高なんですけど
そううまくいかないんですね
いろいろ問題が起こるんですよ
都合が悪くなるんです
それで自分をコントロールするんです
バレないところだけで悪いことをして
バレるところになってくるとやめるんです
だから極悪人はいない
だからだから言ってもう善人もいないし
人間はもうそれほど悪くないと言っても
どういうことかというと
バレなきゃ悪いことをする
もし誰かにバレるんだったら気をつける
我々持っている道徳っていうのはその程度なんです
他人にバレなかったら全然遠慮はしません
社会に 家族に 目上の人に
友達に見張られているならば
まあ気をつけるということなんです
その法則あるんだから
世の中で極悪人っていうのはもういないっていうことになるんです
しかし 善人にもなれない
だからといっていい人間になろうかなと思っても
そう善人になることもないんですね
だから心の家が不道徳だから
心の本来 心の本来の衝動は悪なので
善の道は簡単ではありません
だから 悪でできている心で善を理解することは難しいでしょう
この土曜日の人に私は徹底的に喧嘩したんですね
慈悲っていうのは全然わかりませんと
意味がないんだと で 私はいろいろたとえで
いろんな例で説明 でもわかりませんと
やり方も全部教えたんです
教えて終わったら ではどういうふうにやればいいんですかとまた聞き込んで
私の反応は 私はたくさん人々が見て付き合ってきたんですよと
でも極悪人に会ったのは初めてですよ
だから世界が別だから
そこら辺で話をやめましょうと
でも本人が自分ほど立派なことをする人間ないという態度でいるんです
私は極悪人の旗を立ててあげたんです
それで善を夢見るが 半端にやるか
途中でやめる 諦めるか
善を宣伝する広告塔になるかですよ
我々はもうわかってもないくせに良いことをしようとする
あるいはしようとしない
いい人間になりたいな
いい人間になりたいなとかね
心軽楽にしたいなとか
もうもうもう私はもう耳にタコが出るまで聞いてるんですよ
いい人間になりたいと
もう泣きながら言うんですよ
私はまるっきり相手にしないんです
褒めてほしいんです さすが立派ですね
今今の今の時代ではね
そう考える人っていうのはないんですねとかね
私は嘘言ってはあかんでしょう
だってもう聞く聞く人が私に言うのは同じことだから
今の世代では 時代ではそんな人間ないんですよと言える
私にはもう誰でもそんなこと言うんだよと
言った途端 向こうも腹が立つんです
自分だけ尊いで聖なる気持ちでいる思っていたのに
このボス何言うんですか？と
二度と口もきけないし
来ないんです だからといって私にちょっと悪いこと嘘も言えないんですよ
だから夢見る人っていうのはいくらでもいる
良い人間になりたいなと
とかね もっとしっかりしたいなと
その中でほんのわずかな人々は
やろうともする 人助けしようとかね
ちょっと真面目に頑張ろうとか
やろうとする人もいるんですよ
しかし 半端なんですね
極めてやるということはしない
あるいは途中でもう嫌になって諦めたという
そういう それはもっといい方法で
一番悪いのはこの善を宣言する広告塔になっちゃうんですね
自分で全然やりません
みんな団結して世界の平和を守りましょうとかね
自然を守りましょうとかね
なんかニュース なんかもう 1年前かな
アザラシ？なんでしたっけ
あのゴマ？なんか動物が川に入ってきたでしょ
あの  アザラシ  アザラシ
これでもうやっぱり自然に返さなくちゃいけないんだとか
あれこれやとか もうかなり運動やってるんです
そこら辺にいる子供たちがなんか可愛い可愛いとかね
まあ見てただけなんですけど
まあそれでは良くないと
あんた方何やってるんです？可愛い可愛いじゃないんだよとか言って捕まえて持って行ったりとか
それ一番たちが悪いやり方なんですよ
世界の平和のために戦いましょうとかね
で 広告塔に 広告塔になるだけ
やろうとはしない やること全部悪いんですけどね
あのグリーンピースにしてもね
暴力しかやってないんですけどね
でも看板は立派です やはりイギリスのやるあの組織は
何といいますか あの えっとえっと Amnesty
International
まあ言葉で言えば人権
権利に対してということでしょ
でも実際何やってるか
自分に嫌な政府 政治を批判するだけなんです
自分たちを応援する場合は黙っているんです
自分たちが応援する 自分たちの気に入っている政府だったら黙っているんです
気に入らなかったら まあ警察に逮捕されたってもレポート書くんです
なんとか人は警察に逮捕したんだと
どういうことだ まあ完全に悪いということはね
これはまあいいレポートもね
役に立つものもあることはあるんですけど
完全に良いわけでもないんです
で 善を行いたいが悪をやってしまうというのは人間に常にある問題です
これも覚えておいてください
で こういう 1行 1行暗記したっても役に立ちますよ
善を行いたいんですよ
だってすごく悪いんだから
でないとね でも結局何やるのかというと悪いことをやっているんです
例えば父親 母親がね 子供をいい人間に育てたいからといって
結局は虐待しちゃうでしょ
子供の自由も奪ったりして
それって明らかに悪行為でしょう
だから人間の問題っていうのは
善を行いたいんだけど
やってしまうのは悪いことなんです
だから善のつもりでやっていることは
よくよく見るといいわけじゃないんです
だから学校でも問題起こるし
家庭の中でも問題起こるし
会社でも問題起こるし
どこでもね まあそれでこの大人はうるさいという鉄則というか
方程式が成り立つんです
まあ私はちょっと砕けて書いてるんですけど
まあ一応その方が分かりやすいと思いますよ
もう大人ってうるさいんだよ
一応おじいさんおばあさんになったらね
結構言われるでしょ うるさいと
子供なんか全然遊んでくれない
良い人間になりなさいとばかり言われる人生です
大人っていうのは 我々は一旦大人になったら
いつでも年下の人々にいい人間になりなさいよ
しっかり勉強しなさいよとかね
いつでもそればっかり言ってるんですよ
だから年下の人が年上の人を見ただけで
もう何言うのかわかってるんだからね
面白いことも何でもないんですよ
だから大人がうるさいということになるんです
みんな大人はうるさいと思って生きてきたのです
だから我々も同じなんですよ
我々ももう大人はうるさいと
で 学校のせい まあ小学生の時でも
随分年上の先生になってくるともううるさい
もう若い先生だったら
もう一応仕事に入ったばっかりで
一年も経ってないんだったら
まあそれなりになんとか何とか抑えることはできます
しかし 経験を積んでるあのプロの先生はもうガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ言うわ
だから子供たちにすぐ嫌われるんです
まあそういうことで まあ一応皆様はどうか分かりませんだけど
私も子供頃は大人ってなんてうるさいんですか
付き合いたくはないんだ
という気持ちはありました
そういうことで 私たちはどんな生き方をするのかというと
大人が言っても言ってもやらない
学校の先生はいくら厳しくても子供はやらない
親がいくら厳しくても子供はやらない
とにかく反発する あまりにも凶暴で
もう面倒向かって反発できないんだったら
もっとひどいことするんだよ
隠れて 一対一でやる場合は
まあそう大胆なことはしません
隠れてやることっていうのは
ものすごいもう怖いこと
怪我出すほどの危ないことはやっちゃうんです
だから我々は教えてもやってくれない社会なんです
だから我々一人一人成長するはずがないんです
成長してないでしょ？社会
昔も今も全然変わってないでしょ
建物なんかできたんだからといって
乗り物できたんだから言って変わったわけじゃないんです
人間は昔と今も同じ もう悪いのは悪いんですよ
嫉妬するわ もう他人の足を引っ張るわ
もう人を殺すわ 強盗するわ
戦争するわ 核兵器なんかいろいろな兵器を作るわ
これ変わってないんです
昔はもう弓やらね そんなものを作っていたんですけど
今は別に別な武器を作っているだけのことです
全然変わってない だから社会は成長しない
[笑い]この問題はどのように解決すれば良いのでしょうか
それでこの問題はどうやって解決すればいいかと
これだけでは答えないんですよ
だって答え簡単に見えそうでしょ
みんないいことすればいいっていうことになるんだけど
やらないでしょうに そんなこと言っても
だからそれは答えじゃないんです
道徳を守ればいいんじゃないかなっていうのは
みんな単純に出す答えなんですよ
問題は道徳守らないんですよ
言っても言っても それで社会は成長しない
ではどうすればいいかっていうことなんです
その答えはもう断言します
仏教以外はないんです
はい  不道徳について釈尊の見方 Buddhist
perspective of ill
お釈迦様はこの上から下を見るのではなく
下から上を目指すというやり方
教えるんです 今まで道徳っていうのは上から下へ言うんですよ
母親が子供に言う 旦那は奥さんに言うという
あるいは奥さんの方が上だったら奥さんが旦那に言うとか
先生は生徒に言う 神様がモーセに言うとか
世の中の道徳というのは上から下へお前やりなさいという道徳なんです
だって母親はじゃあ二人で勉強しましょうってことじゃないでしょ
しっかり勉強しなさいってことでしょ
私は忙しい ジャガイモの皮むかなくちゃいけないんだと
ということでしょう 洗濯物干さなくちゃいけないんだから
テレビ見ないで勉強しなさい
だから道徳っていうのは上から下へ言うものになってます
世の中は 世界の道徳は
宗教の道徳は 社会の道徳
家族の道徳 何であろうとも上から下へ言うものです
で お釈迦様はそれを逆にするんです
下から上を目指すという
で あの それが正しい逆方向で
言葉だけ繰り返してみると
上から下へ言うんじゃなくて
下から上へ言うと道徳機能するんです
例えば子供が親に向かって 「
なんであんた失礼な言葉使っているんでしょうか」と 「
言葉品がないんだよ」と
一回でも子供に言われるとやらないんですよ
母親が一日無駄話ばっかりやってるんだと
無駄話よくないんだよと
子供はもう子供なりにもうあまりろくに言葉を喋らないんですけど
言ったらじーんと聞くんですよ
なんか何か包丁で刺されたような感じ
でもそれは成り立たない
子供は知らないんだからね
善悪は だから子供に道徳を教えてもらうということは
まあもう馬鹿げた話で成り立たない
ですから 下から上を目指す方法で道徳を設定するんです
押し付けられた道徳が喜んで抱くものに変わる
今まで我々にとって道徳っていうのは押し付けられたもの
嫌なもんなんですよ それ
ブッダの説明聞くと 「
あ 私も是非やりたいんだ」と
やり方教えてくださいという気分になるんです
そうなっちゃうと社会は成長するんです
それで順番で これ大変な難しいテーマになります
今まで世の中でなかった考え方だからね
このブッダの見方っていうのは
結構ゆっくりとやらないといけないんです
不道徳の本性を見破る
まあいくらかやりましたけど
不道徳ってどういうものかと
本性を見破らなくちゃいけない
で 我々の心の家であることなんですけど
不道徳は楽しいもののように見えるのです
不道徳っていうのは楽しいものなんですよ
麻薬使うことも 酒飲むことも
賭け事も もうなんだかんだで楽しいんですよ
嘘を言うことも 人を騙すことも
人をいじめることも 楽しい
根性を見破ることで 不道徳は避けるべきものだと理解できる
納得もいく しかし 不道徳というのは実際何ものかと
本当に楽しいものかと見破ってみると
これがとんでもない恐ろしいものであると
逃げようと思うんです
不道徳に納得してないんですよ
道徳にも納得してない
だからやらないだけ まあただのただの例えなんですけど
美しいからといって人は火を触らないでしょ
火は炎っていうのはすごく美しいでしょ
ものすごい綺麗です 綺麗だから
じゃあ触りましょうと
誰も触りません なぜかというと
こんな触っちゃうと火傷するんだと
危ないんだとわかるでしょうに
だから触ろうとはしない
そのようにいくら楽しく見えてもやろうとしないことになるんです
不道徳を避けることも自然にできる
もし火が触ったら火傷するんだよということを我々知ってるでしょうに
だからお説教しなくても人は火は触りません
子供を見張っておかなくても
いくらか物事わかる子供だったら火は触ることはしない
それが子供ってすっごい不自由なことですかね
皆様にとっても 火を触ったりしないことをすごく不自由感じていますかね？なんて不自由でしょうかと
全然感じないでしょ そんなのは当たり前で
熱い鍋なんかは手では触ろうとしないでしょ
なんて不自由でしょうか
誰も感じません そのように不道徳も自然に守ることになるんです
わかったら それでまあこのまあ本性を破る仕事なんですけど
まず不道徳はなぜ悪いの？ということ
人は必ず聞くべき質問
問題ですよ この根性がないからこそ
世界は悪いままになっている
この根性がないんですよ
母親が嘘を言うな言ったら
なんで嘘を言うのはそんなに悪いんですか？と聞かないんです
人を殺すなと そんなに悪いんですか？人を殺すこと
と聞かないんでしょ この根性のなささがね
ものすごい危なくて 世界は全然道徳を守らないんです
私はその質問を出してほしいんですよ
私はと言ったら仏教は
そこでそれは世界に出しちゃうと
世界はものすごい混乱に陥っちゃうんです
で いまだに覚えてますけど
かなり前 ある小学生がね
なぜ人を殺すのは悪いんですか？とどこかで言ってしまって
これで日本中大騒ぎ たった一人の頭のいい子供の
言葉で みんなびっくりして大騒ぎになって
そんな そんなのは当たり前やというバカがいるわ
まあ人を殺すは悪いには決まってるんだというバカもいるわ
それでいろんな各仏教の各宗派からいろいろ論文書くわ
冊子の記事書くわ どちら読んでみたって
みんな引っかかってるんで誰も答え持ってないんです
それで子供に負けちゃったんです
結局はあなた方は自分でもわかってないくせに言ってるんではないかと
いまだに私は思いますよ
みんな答え持ってないんだと
持ってます？なんで人を殺して悪いんですか？だから真剣に考えてほしい
我々は道徳知らないんですよ
みんなの答えてるの全部ピント外れなんです
だってみんな言ってるんだからと言うでしょ
みんな言ってることは知ってます
聞いてるのはなぜそれ悪いんですか？なんです
それで次の答え だってキリスト教でもイスラム教でも仏教でも言ってるんではないかと
それは知ってますけど
知りたいのはなぜそれが悪いんですかということなんです
言ってるんだから正しいじゃないでしょ
例えば聖書でアダムとイブで人間初作ったと書いてるでしょうに
で 言ってるんだからって
それ正しいわけじゃないでしょうに
だからそういうのは答えじゃないんです
だから本当に我々はみんないじめられてますからね
いい人間になりなさいとかね
しっかり勉強しなさいとかね
ちゃんと仕事をしなさいとかね
家事はしっかりやりなさいとかね
家計簿をしっかりつけなさいとか
無駄遣いするなよとかね
いろいろ言われているでしょうに
かなりいじめでいじめられてるでしょうに
だったらなんでそれは
言い返せないんですかね
根性がないんです すぐ頭を下げて
わかったようなふりをする
大変わかりました そこで今日は説明できるかどうか
一応説明するといきます
答え出します 答え出してから
この何て言いますか この
こういうことでこの答えですよと
難しい数学みたいなもんなんです
答えあるんだけど その答えは説明しなくちゃいけないんです
不道徳は成功を妨げる
能力を低下させる 幸福楽しみを壊す
人を有限的で惨めな存在に築き上げる
人間というのは随分自分が小さいと感じているんでしょう
私はそう思いますけど
自分がすごい大胆な偉大なる人物やとはあまり思わないんです
まあ最低私は思わないんで
自分のことを 小さいんだと
できることなんかはほんのわずかで限ってるんだと
これで惨めなんですよ
結局は この不道徳が我々は小さな狭い惨めな人間にしているんです
期待 希望 努力などは実らないようにする
もし皆様の期待 希望 努力
何でも実っているならば
この話はちょっと通じませんだけどね
私が知ってる限りは なかなか期待あっても叶うわけじゃないんですね
希望があっても成功できるわけじゃないんですよ
努力してもうまくいくということはないんです
それが不道徳のせいなんです
それで生きる目的をなくす
ただニンジンぶら下がってるような感じで我々生きてるんですけど
何のために生きているのか全然人生って虚しいでしょ
年取ってくたびれて死ぬだけでしょ
誰でも 何やっても結局
それで これが誰も目指してないでしょ
誰も成功したくないと思う人がいますか？ちっちゃな子供でもやることは成功したいでしょうに
能力低下することは誰が好むんですかね
赤ちゃんでもちょっと立っただけで母親にずいぶん喜んでほしいでしょうに
全く立てない場合はもうすごく嫌なんです
私はある子供を試してみたんです
あのもう体が大きいんですよ
小さいんだけど まあ他の子供よりは
で見たら そんな体大きいんだから体力もあるでしょうと
まあ赤ちゃん まあ一歳ぐらいでしたけどね
同時に子供の場合 もう頭がでっかいでしょ
体と比べてみると だからあの年の他の子供はみんな立ってるんです
この子は立てないんです
それで私はそれにしてもとにかく立たせようとする
これはすごく嫌で嫌で全然遊んでくれない
何とか来たら私はすぐはい
立ちましょうと わざとやらせるんです
で 私は知ってます その子供の体格から見ると
他の子は一歳ではきちんと立ちますけど
この子にはできないんだと
もうちょっと時間かかるんだよと
だから私は足に力がつけるように
ちょっと時々 あの まあもうもう何て言いますか
そうやって体はこういう風に動かしたり
いろいろしてあげたんだけど
それは母親やらなくちゃいけない仕事で
あの それをわかってはいるんですけど
ちょっといじめたいんですね
では立ちましょうと言った途端
もう はいはいね 出ていくんです
だからそれで何がわかるのかというと
能力低下するということは赤ちゃんさえ嫌がるんですよ
不幸になりたいと 楽しくはしたくないんだと思う人はいないでしょう
惨めな存在になりたい人間もいないでしょう
犬猫さえも惨めにはなりたくないんですよ
そういうことだからなんですよ
悪いことするなよという
当たり前でしょう だから
それ答えなんです まだ成立はしてないんです
これは質問があって答えがある
どのようにこの答えに行くのかという
数学の場合はちゃんと過程を説明しないと答えだけ出してももう正しい答えになりません
だからね プルーフと言うんですね
あれは それが必要なね
证明は必要なんです だから不道徳はなぜ悪いの？というのが答え
した答えを覚えておいてください
もしこの答えならば もしこれが証明できれば
道徳も悪の 当たり前のことなんですよ
人は毒食べては飲んではいけないとかね
火を触ってはいけないとか
赤信号を渡ってはいけないということと同じなんです
もっと明確なんです 赤信号でも渡っても死ぬわけじゃないんだから
だって私は毎日のように渡ってますからね
あの法然坊ちゃんのところに行くと赤信号ありますけど
一度も緑になるまで待ったことはないんです
まだ死んでないんです
で それよりも火を触っただけで火傷するっていうことでもないでしょ
時々いろんなこのね もうなんて言いますか
いろんな変なことを人に見せて人を喜ばせた人々もいろんなことやるでしょ
火を触ったりする ある韓国の人が来て
あの鉛を溶かして口に入れちゃったんです
もう信じられない 鉛っていうのはすっごい温度でしょ？何度でしたっけ？鉛
まあぐらいあたりでしょう
おそらく 溶ける温度は
口に入れて で もうそれで固まってるでしょ
固まったらテレビで見たんですけど
そちらの人 誰かにはいはいどうぞとあげたら
その人はもう数時間後死ぬと
だから 確実に火を触ったら火傷するっていうわけでもないんですよ
時々訓練して火を触れるようにということもできないわけでもないんですよ
道路の両側も車がなければ
赤信号を渡ってもね 死ぬわけじゃないんです
しかし 道徳は明確に確実なんです
毒飲んだらひどい目に遭うでしょうね
と同じなんです はい そういうことで
じゃあ証明の方にうっかり進んでみます
あれ 仏教の不道徳 時代
社会 文化などによって変わらない普遍的な不道徳があります
あの もう道徳 不道徳というと
もう嫌になるほどあるでしょうに
大きい声でしゃべってはいけないとかね
人にしゃべる場合は 何て言いますか
わかりやすくしゃべりなさい
そんなのは道徳でしょ
だらしない服装で社会に入るなよとかね
会社に行くんだったらちゃんと背広で行きなさいとかね
普段着で行くなよとかね
そんなのはもうどれぐらいあるかというと
もうわからない 無数に無限に作るのは作るは毎日増えるは毎日減るは
だからそれではもう科学的に話にならんだから
仏教はこの普遍的な道徳をじっとこれぐらいだとはっきり言ってるんです
これ一部だけ 今日紹介するのは
また角度を変えて変えて
別なところでまたセット
セットいろいろあります
お釈迦様のすごいことはこれで終わりと
これ以上ないんだとはっきり言うところなんです
だから このヨーロッパの宗教みたいに
この個人個人の説明で自分の宗教を作るってことはできない
はい これは四つです 五番目はありませんと
だから人類について語るんだから
これ並大抵の知恵じゃないんです
だからまあ仏教を勉強する人々は数字に結構慣れてると思いますよ
生命って何なのかというと
つで五蘊にしている 真理はといえば四つだよとしている
悟るために揃えなくちゃ条件どれぐらいある？というと
まあ全部揃っちゃうとになります
でもそれダブってますけど
まあ短く言ってくださいと言ったら
まあ七つぐらいですよと
正しい道はこれは八種類だよと
全部数字で すごいでしょう
八は私は九にするそうと
それはできない 私は一つ減って七つにするそうと
それもできない それでお釈迦様は他人の他人が分かってないってことを知ってるんだからね
たまにからかうんですよ
私はからかうよりはすごくきついですけどね
あるバラモン人が立派な人間の今思い出して言うんだから
参考的のは今日読んでないんです
間違う可能性あります
完全なバラモンなんですね
バラモンは立派な人間で
他の人間は立派じゃないという立場をバラモン教は知っているんです
だから立派なバラモンになるためには条件五つだよと
一 とても体格が良くて美しいであること
男前に 明るい色で 二 七代目まで母親も父親も純血でバラモン人であること
三は三ヴェーダを知り尽くしていること
四 道徳的な人間であること
五 知恵があること 私たちの教えではこの五つが完成すれば立派なバラモン人だと言いますよと
お釈迦様 そうですか よくわかりますか
あのね この五つの中で一つぐらい削減できないんですか？と聞いたんです
自分の知恵で考えて 言ったらこのバラモンにはすごく胸を張って
自分よく物事を知ってるんだということを見せたいでしょう
できますよ だってものすごい体格よくかっこいい男で色白であるとか
そんなのは何の意味もないんだよ
それを削減できますよ
あ そう ということは四つあればいいということでしょう
まあ四つあれば あのね
この四つの中で一つ もう一つできないんですかね
削減することが とこの人はこの七代目までバラモン
両親もバラモンであるということは
あんなのはもう何の意味もないんだと
どう考えたって それ削減できますよと
七代まで知らなくてもまあ大丈夫だと
はい わかります ということは三つで十分ということ
はい そうです ではバラモン
私は考えてこの三つの中からもう一つ減ることできないんですかねと
このバラモンが見事にやられていますよ
偉そうな五つだと言ったってもう減っていくんだから
このバラモンが やっぱりよくも考えると
この三ヴェーダを丸暗記して知り尽くしておくっていうことは
みんなにできるわけでもないし
かなり勉強好きな人でないとできないし
それってそんなに必要な条件じゃないんだよと
堂々と言うんです よくわかる
それで二つ残ったんですね
と言ったら バラモン この二つの中から一つ減ることは削除することできますか？残ったのは道徳的な人間であることと
知恵があること 頭が良いこと
たら このバラモンがお釈迦様
それできん この二つはもう減ることはできない
頭が良くたっても道徳ない人っていうのは悪人で何の役にも立ちませんよと
道徳なんかあったっても
頭が悪いんだったらもう何の人間ではでしょうかと
だからシーラとパンニャですね
知恵と戒と慧ですね これは互いに支え合っているんだ
それでお釈迦様その通りですと
言ってブッダの説法するんです
必要なのは道徳と知恵だけですよと
だからブッダのね 弁証法というかね
論争法ね で あなた方は分かってないということもちゃんと言ってます
逆にお釈迦様が自分が四つだと言ったら四つだよと
減らすことはできないんだと
人間には だからこの順番
いろいろ数字いっぱい仏教でありますよ
仏教経典 特に原始経典を読んでみると
まあ数字 数字 数字 数字だらけで
それぐらいもうもう胸を張って言ってるんですよ
人類にチャレンジして
できればチャレンジしなさいと
あの それは別に脅してるんじゃないんです
チャレンジして欲しいんですよ
まあ必ず負けますよ 負けても恥じゃないんです
チャレンジしたところで自分がガクンと真理はわかるんです
そういうことで このアビダンマテキストからまとめて14があるんです
しかし 人間の生き方 社会システムによって
これは複数に増えてしまうこともあり得る
複数に増えたっても もともとは14だと
例えば怒りという言葉がありますね
怒りっていうのは不道徳でしょ
怒りもいろいろあるんですよ
機嫌が悪いのも怒りであって
人を殺したくなるのも怒りであって
大量に人を殺したくなるのも怒りであって
例えばこのテロとかなんとかやってる人々は
もうひどく自爆までして人を殺したりする
日本では何とかちょっとしたことで誰かを知ってる人を殺すとかね
それぞれ怒り違うんですね
だからまあそれなりに社会システムによって変わるかもしれませんだけど
本来は怒りという一言葉でまとめられます
はい それで心の本来の衝動は 3つに分けられる
これからこの証明していくんです
結構難しくなるかどうか分かりませんだけど
今日の授業は早く終わると思います
人間の本来の衝動っていうのは
漏・欲・怒・痴という 3つなんです
欲と怒りと無知と これ日本語でみんな貪瞋痴と覚えてるんだから
そういう風にしてますけど
パーリ語で時々漏・欲・怒・痴と言うんですけど
本当は順番が逆なんです
妄想が上に来なくちゃいけないけど
まあそれはそれでよろしいし
我々結局はこの欲と怒りと無知という衝動で生きてるんですよ
もし反対意見ある方々は今時間ないんだから
自分がどんな気持ちで生きているのかと自分の心に聞いてみてください
自分の子供可愛いでしょ
それ欲なんです 子供が悪いことすると腹が立つでしょ
私は子供愛してるんだからってそんなことない
ただ腹が立ってるだけなんです
怒りなんです 会社であいつには負けてたまるのかと言ってバリバリ頑張る場合はね
リストラにならないようにとかなんとかやってる場合は
なんだあれって 怒りか欲でしょ
今の震災に何か 寄付しても向こうはありがとうございますと言わなかったら腹が立つんですよ
もし募金にお金を当ててあんたこれぐらいでもうちょっと出せと言われたらどうする？あんた 100円ぽっちで何もできんでしょうと
もし募金箱を持ってる人が言ったらどうする？だからそんなことをしたっても
結局は貪瞋痴の衝動なんです
だからみんなこのリトマス紙に合わせてないだけ
自分の心は リトマス紙
試験紙でしたっけ このまあ調べる液体に入れてないんです
赤く出るか青く出るかと
だから生命の本来の衝動は貪瞋痴なんです
むさぼりと怒りと無知なんです
はい そこで貪瞋痴に属する不善
で 不善はやっぱり十善ばっかり羅列したっても意味がないんだから
ちゃんとカテゴリに分けて言わないと人間には覚えにくいんです
そこで無知のカテゴリには七つあるんです
一番目はモーヘ これは無知っていうことでね
だいたいあの感じ まあこのテキスト
今日はものすごくもう私は発音がわからないわ
もうワープロから漢字出すわ
わからない ものすごい苦労しましたけど
この漢字を出してもらうために
で モーヘ 知なんでね これ無知の知なんですね
ありのまま事実真理わからないということは
誰でも本来の状態なんです
それから二番目 アヒリカというんですね
これ読み方は無惨だと思いますけどね
合ってますか？この漢字は
慚愧の これ以外にすごい現象で
今日ちょっとだけ意味を説明します
あの一般的な俗語で言えば
この恥じらないというね
恥だと思わない よくこの子供見るとね
大人だったらすごく恥ずかしがるものっていうのは堂々とやっちゃうでしょ
だから子供は物事を知らんだからね
例えばまあ興味あったら
ちっちゃな子供なんかは女性のスカートの中にも入ったりするんですよ
見たいと思ったら平気でもう何のこともない
大人は絶対やらんでしょうに
で まあこのアヒリカっていうのは
この無慚愧 恥じらないっていうこと
恥じらないんだから平気で悪いことできるんですよ
恥ずかしいと思っちゃうとできないんですね
それで二番目はアノッタって無愧と書くんです
言うんですけど これは怖がらない
これ勇気あるって意味じゃないんだよ
バカっていうことなんですよ
私は勇気あるんだから
クマ クマをもう触ってみるぞとかね
抱っこしてみるぞとか
それっていうのは勇気じゃなくてバカでクマに食べられちゃうでしょうに
殺されるでしょうに だから怖い
子供は怖いんですよ それ知らない
だからそれも一つの不道徳なんです
次にこのウッダッチャということ
これ発音がジョウコ  ジョウコ
でというのはこの興奮状態
混乱状態 集中力の反対なんですね
これまた子供の場合は明らかなんです
いつでももう落ち着いてないでしょ
興奮状態で 大人が 10人いたってもそんなに大騒ぎないんですけど
子供一人が入っちゃうと
もう全部家丸ごと占領しちゃうんですね
あれは興奮状態でいるんだから
だから俗世間では子供は何の罪もない可愛い綺麗なものよと思っても
仏教から見れば悪の塊なんです
怖いことは知らないわ
恥は知らないわ もう完璧な情動状態で興奮状態でいるわ
5番目はティーナ ティーナというのは何かだるいみたい
これ心の状態 体のだるさじゃないんですね
困沈ですね あまり機能しない
だるくて硬くて 心が滑らかじゃないんです
6番はミッド 睡眠ですね
このだるい状態がちょっとひどくなるともう寝てしまうんですね
7番目はヴィチキッチャ
疑 いわゆる物事はっきりしない
どうでしょうねとかね
特にこの大人の会話の場合でもよくわかりますよ
誰が疑であるんでしょうかと
何もアイデアを貢献しないんですね
ああ そうですかね ああ
面白いですね どうでしょうかねとかね
そういう会話の場から
私はいくら仕事があっても逃げちゃう
もういつまで経ってもやれない
あまりにも変で無駄話になるんです
だから自分で何かこれはこれ
あれはあれとわかった方がいいんですよ
間違っても構いませんよ
別に相手があなたそう言うんだけど
それは間違いだよ ああそうですか
あ なるほど それで終わりますからね
間違いですか？だから別に我々の意見
間違って悪いわけじゃないんですよ
まあ何がということははっきりしてほしいんですね
ですから疑っていうのは
この そういうことで あの物事を疑ってみるという知識的なことじゃないんです
知識世界ではね 疑ってかかれて言うでしょ
それが知識的な興味で疑ってわけじゃないんです
知りたい野郎 知りたいよと
調べてやろうではないかということで
それは仏教は認めるんです
しかし ああ そうですかねっていうのはね
とんでもない不道徳なんです
それはこの無知に入る不道徳なんです
そこでローバ 欲に入る不道徳
また 3つなんです  1番目ローバ
むさぼりですね  2番目ディッティ
これ 2番目に書いた見解ディッティと
こちら 7番目に書いているのは無知の 7番目
正反対なんです だから簡単じゃない
私はこれはこれだと思ってますよと
という言葉で またすごい危険なんです
例えば自分の考え方に
見解にずいぶんしがみついちゃって
いくら言っても変えません
それから人が違う意見で言うと腹が立ってくるんです
この人 私の意見に逆らってるんではないかと
私の意見を批判しているのではないかと
それが疑と全く反対 何かへんてこりんな考え方を持って
それにしがみついている
だから何も意見を持たないことも不善ですよ
何か持った意見にしがみついていることも不善なんです
だから難しいんですよ
まあ難しいね 正しい答えを出しますけど
これは今日のテーマじゃないんだけど
我々はその場その場で入った情報によって意見を作る
でももしかするとこれがね
別なデータが入っちゃうと変わるかもしれませんよと
日本はね イラクは確実に破壊兵器を持ってるんだと
なんたることですか 認め難いとかね
国会で言っていて あれで何 1本もないんだと
別にそれでいいんじゃないかと私は思いますよ
それでも戦争するのは正しいって結論できたんだからね
後であるいは間違いと言うでしょうね
五 六年経ったところで
人身あったところで ですから
人間いうことっていうのはそんなにしがみついて信じる必要もないし
自分の意見 この場合は
自分の意見も流動的で
新しいデータが入ったら古い意見を変えると
堂々と そうすると我々はどんどん成長していくんです
だから何も意見ないことも不善で
仏教では 自分の意見にしがみつくことも不善にしているんです
なんでカテゴリー別にしたんですかというと
同じ心で同時にディッティという見解とディッティというものは一緒には思われませんよ
性格的に正反対だから
同じ心でどうでしょうかねと言いながら
私はこう思っているよということはありえないんです
このカテゴリーにしているのはそういうわけで
一緒になったりならなかったり場合
すごく複雑なシステムです
これ で この この何て言いますか
この一緒に行動するもの
それから絶対一緒に行動しない不善とかね
そのチャートがあるんです
まあ今日は時間もないし
それからまあ難しくなっちゃうしね
チャートがなくても説明はできないわけないんですけど
それで三番目 漏破の三番目はマーナ
マンですね マンっていうのは自分を測るんですね
私は何者ですかと 他人と比較するんです
これって罪ですよ 仏教では
それでこの漏破は この無知の一
二 三 四と一緒に機能するんです
一 二 三 モーハ アイディカ
アノッタッパ ウッダッチヤ
この四つと漏破が機能するんです
漏破一人で漏破だけでは機能しない
漏破というのは欲ですね
例えば頭が欲に絡んじゃうと必ず興奮状態にいるでしょ
もう集中できる状態じゃないんです
それで恥知らない状態にいる
怖いもの知らない状態にいる
それで不倫でも何でもする
だからこの貪りというものが
このモーハ アイディカ
アノッタッパ ウッダッチヤ
あの 痴と無惨と無記と情動セットでモノになるんです
で それから怒りのセットに行きます
怒りの場合は 怒りに属する不善は四つですね
1番目は怒り 誕生日 怒りっていうのはわかりやすいんですよ
この まあ嫌という気持ちなんですね
受け入れがたい 反対する感情って
例えばあなたの意見には反対ですというのは怒りじゃないんです
別に感情的じゃないんだからね
感情的に反対する それは怒り
心とか  2番目は一差 これは嫉妬なんですね
漢字1字になってるほどの読み方ですか
え 嫉 これは嫉妬ということ
嫉妬っていうのはもう他人のことを認めないんですね
あの方は美人じゃと認めないことは嫉妬なんです
だから怒りに似ています
怒りの仲間なんです 自分のネックレスよりは隣の奥さんつけてるネックレスの方が美しくて高いと認めないとね
それでまっちゃう 日本語で何と言いますか
物惜しみ  物惜しみですね
まっちゃりっていうのは
自分のものを他人と共同することが嫌がるんです
触らない あげません 貸してもあげません
私のもの それも怒りの仲間なんです
4番目 クックーっちゃ後悔ですね
はぁ 失敗しちゃったとか
はぁ 悪いことをしちゃったとかね
私はなんというバカでしょうかとか
これ怒りの仲間な気分悪いです
思っちゃうと気分悪ければ怒りなんです
気分が良ければ欲なんです
どうなっても人は興奮状態でいて
物事の判断できない状態なんです
これも無知の 1 2 3 4 で行動するんですね
もう入りが乗ったと歌っちゃった
要するに 4つ入らないと機能しない
死んじゃうんです だから我々の悪を生かしているのは無知なんですよ
だから仏教は無明とかね
智慧とかね ものすごい堂々と強烈な方っていうのはそういうわけで
我々の悪をね 生かしているのは無知
はい このリスト見て何がわかるんですかね
今まで皆様方聞いた不道徳っていうのは
人のものを盗るなよとかね
他人様に邪魔するなよとかね
嘘を言うなよとかね そんなもんでしょ
でもブッダになってみるとえらい違うんじゃないんですかね
そこはすごく気づいてほしいんです
泥棒するなよとかね 万引きするなよとか
18 歳にもなってないんだからタバコするなよとかね
我々知ってるのはそんな程度の道徳なんですけど
仏教ではそういうのは扱ってないんです
全く別なこと言ってるんです
はい 次に行きます 不善は心理的な現象です
だから嘘を言うなよという社会的な現象じゃなくて
心理的な現象なんです
盗むなよっていうのは社会的な現象でしょ
それは警察ぐらい真面目に働けば
人は盗まないでしょうに
あるいはこの今みんなセキュリティとかなんとかいろいろつけてるでしょ
それでも空き巣に入るでしょ
私は推薦したいのは もうもう家に入るとものすごくパチパチと打てるように
期間中でもまあ 4本ぐらいつけておけば誰も来ないんです
わからないところをちゃんと人の高さを計算して狙いを定めて
赤外線でセンサーつけちゃって置いておけば誰も来ないでしょ
それだったら空き巣 しかもセキュリティ終わったっても全然もうダメージも入りますけどね
だから私は言いたいのはこういうこと
あんなのは社会的な現象で
警察でもしっかりしているならば
空き巣に入っても処刑やというならば
もう誰もやりませんよ
弁護士を立てることを禁止するとかね
それでみんな何言うんでしょうか
人間の自由はどうするんで
やっぱり悪いことしたいでしょ
人権はどうするのかとかね
だから人権とか人間の自由っていうのは悪を犯す人権なんです
本当の人権は認めてないんで
だって黒人を差別してるでしょうに
堂々と 宗教違っただけで
生活はちょっと生活習慣が変わっただけで
もう派手に差別するでしょうに
アメリカの選挙なんか
州徹反対か賛成か ただそれだけでも決めるもんだからね
そんな程度です ですから
もう差別のいいところで自由自由っていうのは悪を犯す自由を言ってるんです
例えば今 私は明確にわかりやすく言ったはずなんですよ
例えば空き巣に入っても死刑だと
別に私は認めているわけじゃないんです
私は人を殺しても犯人を殺すなよという仏教的な意見はありますけど
ただまあわかりやすくするために言いますけど
空き巣に入ったら死刑だと
弁護士も立つことは禁止するんだと
そんな風な残酷な法律作っちゃうと誰がやるんですかね
だから泥棒するなよということは社会的な現象です
嘘を言うなよということは社会的な現象です
ブッダが教える道徳っていうのは社会的な現象じゃないんです
心理的な現象なんです
それがいくら警察がいてもダメなんですね
したがって 自分の主観的な態度によってどこまででも増幅する
だから社会と関係ないんだから
例えば怒りが社会と関係ないんですよ
自分が主観的に怒ったんです
それにその怒りはいくらでも増幅できるんです
外から関係ないんだから
例えば人にいじめられた
あるいは一言葉言われたという
ほんのちょっとの火種があるかもしれませんよ
それで家に帰ってから自分の部屋に閉じ込んでとことんとことんとことん
それを考えて考えて考えて
いても立ってもいられない状態まで怒りを増幅することはできるんです
相手がものすごく冗談で
その人は仲間だから仲間で友達じゃないかということで言ったかもしれませんよ
でもこの人は自分の部屋に入って
この怒りを増幅して増幅して
もう我慢できない あいつを殺さなくちゃいけないからと言って
すぐその人を殺す可能性もあります
そこが不道徳の危険なところなんです
不道徳は心理的な現象
もう勝手に主観的に現れるもの
それであの前のリストを見ると
あの無地のリストっていうのが子供だったらもうもうものすごい派手にあるでしょ
[背景音楽]欲と怒りはそれほど機能しないんだけど
子供赤ちゃんとか一歳二歳
三歳まではね もう無知の七つはもうありったけにあるでしょう
そういうことで この我々にはこのもう付いてるんです
この心理的現象 不善 不道徳という心理的現象がもうついているんです
そこは危ないところは勝手に増幅する
考え方次第 考え方次第で極悪人にもなる
または消してしまうこともできる
悪いだけじゃないんですよ
もう自分が勝手に考えて怒ったんだから
もうまるっきり怒りを取り消すと
それもできます だから心理的な状況だからできるんです
社会的なことだったらできません
だから社会現象はあまり派手にしゃべるもんじゃないんです
社会はずっと変わるんだからね
我々はいくら説教しても社会から人殺し取り消すっていうことはできん
しかし 人間の心から根絶することはできます
この際の能力 幸福を破壊する自爆的な因子であることも明らかです
だから 自分の心で我々は自爆的な因子を持ってるんです
怒りでも爆発するかも
欲でも爆発するかも 嫉妬でも爆発するかも
あのリスト一つだけでも増幅しちゃうと大変なことになります
例えば嫉妬 ちらっと嫉妬したことで家に帰って落ち込んじゃって
どんどん嫉妬を増幅させるとどうなるんですかね
とんでもないことになりますよ
それで幸福になりませんよ
はい 悪の悪性について具体例
まあちょっとした具体例で説明します
人は貪りの衝動で行動をします
例えば 例えば話で ある人が貪りがあって
欲があって まあ行動しようとする
だからこの欲っていうのは
何か見て欲が出てくるでしょ
何か見たら欲が出てくる
貪りが出てくる そうすると自分のものにしたいと思っちゃう
獲得したいと思うでしょ？いう気持ちが優先になります
あれって綺麗だなと思った瞬間ね
欲が出るでしょうね そうすると周りが見えなくなっちゃって
あ 欲しい欲しい とにかく手に入りたいと
何をしてでも手に入れたいという気持ちが生まれてくるんです
周りの状況が見えなくなります
したがって理不尽な行動をしてしまいます
すぐに全くの理不尽な行動をしてしまうんです
欲しいんだから そこで相手はどうなるのかと
例えば人の奥さんの方がもう好きになってしまったと
自分のものにしたくなったと
というと 相手もそれに気づくでしょうに
相手が社会がこの貪りに気づきます
それで社会は与えない
自分の利益を守りたいという気持ちが相手の心に生じる
相手にまで毒を降らす
まき散らすんですよ 例えば
私が何か高価なものを持っている
誰かがそれを見て欲しいなと思っちゃうでしょうね
思った途端 もうむちゃくちゃ理不尽な行動をする
そうすると私がこいつはこれ狙ってるんだと絶対あげませんという風に
私の心にも余計な欲が生まれるんです
電気と同じ電気 あれ？なんて言いますか
インダクション こちらの電気だとこちらの電気が生まれるというね
電気誘導ですかね  トランスで送る現象なんですけど
まあ共鳴するみたいなもんなんですよ
共鳴と言えば同じことで共鳴でもないんですけどね
こちらでこれをやると
あちらであれが生まれるということ
だから私が持っているものに対して
誰かが欲をそそっちゃうと
私もたちまち欲をそそってしまうんです
普段は全然気にしなかったんですけど
時々誰か私の部屋に来て
これいいなと言うと 私はあげようかなと
あげたら困るんだ私と思っちゃうんですよ
いや 別にもう本当はあってもなくてもどうでもいい
蹴っ飛ばしたり もうもうもうしたものなんですけど
誰かが欲しいと欲だと
あ あれあげちゃうとどうしよう
どうするのかと それにもうかなり昔気づいちゃって
それからもう欲しいって言ったらあげると
もう決めちゃったんです
それ以上考えないんだ
考えちゃうと困る 心汚れるんだから
そこでこの心理的な問題のシステム見えますかね
自分が一人で欲張ってるわけじゃなくて
社会にまでこの毒をまき散らすんです
で それでむさぼり同士の争いが生じます
それで争いが生じるでしょ
こちらは人の奥さんを自分のものにしたいと思ってます
向こう奥さんの旦那も
もうそれは許すわけないでしょうに
争いが生じますね 獲得そのことは厳しい戦いの結果になります
だから我々はほんのちっぽけなものでも
自分のものにするためにものすごい戦わなくちゃいけないんですよ
800円欲しいんだったら
もうコンビニで 1時間も仕事しなくちゃただではくれません
戦いで勝っても それから仕事で勝って儲かったとかね
商売で勝って儲かったと
ボロ儲けしたと言っても
自分も怪我や損するのです
戦いっていうのはもう怪我なしに終わらないでしょうに
アメリカはイラク戦争に勝ちましたと言うんだけど
より大きく損しているのは誰ですかというとアメリカでしょう
イラク人のものは家とか全部もう破られましたけど
まあいろいろ全部なくなったと
それで終わっちゃいますけどね
アメリカの若者は一人一人死んでいくことはありがたいことじゃないでしょう
イラク人は 4人死んだってアメリカ知らんふりするんですけど
アメリカの若者が一人死んじゃったらもうすごいお金払わなくちゃあかんでしょうに
結局は損していますよ
だから我々皆様戦争に行かないんだけど
会社で戦っているでしょうし
家庭で戦っているでしょうし
何か欲しいものを手に入れるために戦っているでしょう
その時も必ず怪我するんです
怪我して自分のものになるんです
結果にすえて満足できないので
さらにむさぼりが燃えます
一旦自分のものにしたっても
それに払った代償がね
多いんだからね なんか満足いかないんですよ
人のお子さんと一緒になりたくて
自分を離婚もして それで子供たちにも会うこともできなくなっちゃって
勝手に離婚するんだから
自分がもうすごい苦労して買ったマンションも奥さんの名義にして
もう痛い放題 もうもう弁償を払って相手と一緒になると
なってみたらもう二人だけの人生で
なんかもう子供がいないわ
子供に会えないわ もう住むところはないわ
もうひどいでしょ ですから
またむさぼりが燃えていきます
得たいが 努力もするが得られないということになります
時々それは別なケースなんですね
何か得たい 何かなりたい
それ努力もする でもこれ欲だからうまくいかないんです
弁護士になりたいんだけど
司法試験は落ちるは落ちるは落ちるはと
それ才能ないってことでしょ
なんで才能ないかというと
あのむさぼりなんです
原因は むさぼりさえなければうまくいくのに
はい 次に読んでみましょうか
これであの 本当は正しいやり方は言わなくちゃいけないんですけど
この時点で では 儲かりたいよ欲がなくてどうやって仕事をすればいいのかとかね
あるんです 方法は 必ず儲かるんです
必ず儲かりたければ欲を捨てなくちゃいけないんです
だからバカにできないんですよ
欲を捨てて儲かるということは
儲かるといえば欲に決まってるでしょうに
だから だからちょっと難しいかも
必要なものを楽に得る方法はそれと正反対のものです
だから欲しい欲しいではなくて
違う働きがあるんです
欲しいものを得るために
しかし 人間は必要ではなく欲しいという感情を引き起こす
これ一つの答えなんです
物は欲しい欲しいではなくて必要かないか
それなんですよ 必要なものに欲も何とも関係ないでしょうに
だから欲は毒で 猛毒で
不道徳で 才能も幸福も全部消しちゃうんです
必要っていうことはしょうがないでしょ
だからブッダが推薦するのは欲ではなくて必要がないか見てみろと
だから人の奥さんが見たら美人かもしれませんだけど
自分にも一人いるんだから
それで結構苦労してるんだから
それで十分でしょう 必要ありませんと
もう新しい問題は でも自分が独身でやっぱり気に入った人は人の奥さんやと
その場合はもしかすると自分は結婚する必要あるでしょ
だからあの夫婦はうまくいってるかないかとか調べたってもいいんです
やっぱりうまくいってないみたいや
チャンスがあるんだと
その場合は別にそれほど問題は起きませんよ
調べたらもう夫婦はものすごく仲が良くて
もう全く隙間がないんだと
じゃあ諦めましょうと
いうことになるんです
だから必要なものにチャレンジするんですよ
挑戦するんですよ バカみたいに欲しいものに挑戦するんじゃないんです
でも誰もその区別わからないんですね
だから世界狂ってるんです
感情が逆さまになることに気づかない
だからそれはこういう意味なんです
得たいと思った感情が得られない感情なんです
持ってるものを消える感情なんです
例えば怒りで相手に勝ちたい
相手を負かせたいと思った感情が
自分が負ける感情なんです
逆さまになってるんです
なぜかというと 我々は本来は悪だからなんです
本来不幸になるようになってます
一番最初に説明しましたからね
2番目のスライドに 必要なものも欲しいものも得られなくなる
結果として必要なものも
欲しいものも 何でも得られなくなっちゃうんです
だから欲は使わない 欲の代わりに必要かないか
だから金に欲を作るんじゃないんです
金が必要かないかと あ
そうすると必要ですから量があるんですよ
どれぐらいあれば十分かという
それぐらいは簡単に手に入ります
でもそこ世間では欲だけだから
金がいくらあってもいくらあっても足らぬと言ってるでしょう
だから世の中はもううまくいっていないということになります
それであのあと基本関係ないんだけど
例えば何か人が何か持っている
持っているものは自分が欲しくなった
それはダメなんです やったらいけない
欲しくなったんじゃなくて
相手が持っているものは自分に必要
それでそれくれとか何とか欲出しちゃうともらえないんです
法則があるんですよ 与えたらくれるという
例えば何か板に何か釘
何か入っている場合は
他の釘を刺すとあの釘が上に来るんです
だから欲しいんだったら与えることなんです
相手に必要なものを探して
あなたにこれ必要でしょう
あ そうなんです では あげますから
私にこれくれと あ いいよと
何のことなく得られます
欲もないし 戦いもない
そういうやり方なんですよ
成功するやり方は はい
次 それで不道徳は精神的な病
病気です 不道徳っていうのは精神的な病気ですよ
冗談じゃないんです 嘘を言うなよって言ったら
そんな冗談世の中で嘘を言わなきゃ生きていられないでしょうと文句言うでしょう
でも精神的な病気はもっとひどいんだからね
精神病はありがたがらないと思います
だから これあの証明のあの過程で
不道徳っていうのは精神的な病気である
人間は精神病は欲しくないでしょ
不道徳はやりたいんだけどね
不道徳はやりたいんだけど
精神的な病気だけは嫌でしょう
ですから 病気で見るんです
しかし 欲 怒りなどの感情は人間に必要だと
感情は豊かな方が良いのだと自慢げに言う
俗世間の間違ったところはそこなんですよ
欲がありがたい 哀愁はいかに美学的に美しいかとかね
気持ち悪いんですけど
で 喜怒哀楽でしたっけ？何言うんですか
こんなのはもうとんでもないんですよ
本当は で 感情っていうのは豊かな方がいいとまた言ってるんです
結局 道徳肯定して不道徳肯定しているんです
不道徳の方がいいと だから哀愁なんかね
映画ドラマ化したりしても
人殺しまでやっちゃうでしょうに
まあ現代ものはあんまり思い出しませんだけど
例えばシェイクスピアのドラマなんか見てもね
もうそういう感情でも殺しまでするでしょう
マクベスやらオテロやらね
いろいろ見てみると だからありがたいわけじゃないんです
ただの精神病だと理解すると
道徳的な人間になることこそが正しい道だとわかるでしょう
だから不道徳っていうのはただの精神病
もう正常じゃないんです
頭がおかしい それわかると
やっぱり道徳の方がいいんだと
もう当たり前でしょ 正常な心でいることは当たり前でしょ
はい もうちょっと戻ってみます
一歩間違えば 以下の現象はどちらでも精神病を引き起こす
だから私は嘘言ってるわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様おっしゃってる不道徳はすべて精神病なんです
一歩間違えば まあどちら説明しましょうか
まあわかりやすい六番目
ミッド あの第一セットの無知のセットの六番目
ミッドっていうのは睡眠でしょ
いつでも寝る どうなる？あれ病気でしょ
朝もこうやって寝て 昼間寝ていると
いるんです そういう病気の人々
いつ見ても寝ている 人の話聞こうと目をあげてもまた寝る
だから寝たいな寝たいなと思って
それ喜んで寝る訓練しちゃうと
確実に精神的な病気になってしまうんです
もう薬漬けになってしまっちゃうんです
大変です 他何か 例えば恥知らない状態になったら
時々いるでしょうね 道路でも街でも電車でも
いきなりもう体もう服を脱いで裸見せたりとか
病気でしょ 我々は見せませんだけどね
まあもうだからまあ あれって正常だと思いますかね
それは今言ったのはあの 一番目のセットの二番目アヒリカ
それで二番目の老婆のセットのあの見解ディッティ見てみましょう
何か自分の意見があって
これこそ正しいと思うとどうなると思いますかね
例えば なんでテロリストの方々は自爆テロをやっていますかね
あれはコーランで書いてるんだから
書いてないんです 嘘ですから
あの でもそんな書いてないとお役で言っちゃうと殺されますけど
私は読んでみたけどそんなことないんです
あのアメリカのバカどもたちにそれは言えないんですね
だから宗教は間違ってるんだよと
宗教は間違った理解してるんだと言えば
まあいくらか目が覚めるでしょう
人々は それは言わない
だから人殺し必要ないんです
で そこで天国に特別なところが自分たちに用意しているんだよとか
そんなことを子供に言うと
子供がこれこそ天国に早く行けるんだとか
それまたあのもう特席
特等席でやられるんだとかね
思って たくさんの人を道連れにして死んじゃう
この昔 キリスト教の戦争したでしょ
明らかに見解のせいでしょ
ローマ法王も戦争に行ったんだから
神こそ正しいやと 危ない危ない
何するかわからなくなっちゃう
だから見解でも一歩間違えば精神病
高慢 ちょっと間違えば高慢で慢
ちょっと間違えば精神病気
病院にいるでしょ 私は大統領
私はあれやこれやとか言ってる人々がね
自分を測っているところでちょっと間違っちゃうんです
ちょっと滑ったら終わり
ものすごい危険なんです
我々ものすごい危険なんですよ
もうそっち怒ったりするんだけど
それをちょっと滑っちゃっただけで
でもうもう精神病気 もう治らないというか
とてつもない危険なものなんです
この十四は ありがたいこと十四しかないんですよ
世界にいるどんな天才の心理学者にも聞いてみてください
まだここまで発見してないんです
例えば怒りの四番目 クンクッチャ
後悔 どう思いますか？後悔したら
ちょっと間違っちゃうと自殺までするでしょ
危ないと言うたらやりゃしないくらい危ないんです
だから不道徳っていうのは明らかに精神病である
病気はありがたいわけじゃないんですよ
体の病気もありがたくないでしょうに
糖尿病はありがたいとか
高血圧はありがたいと思う人いないでしょうに
赤ちゃんには悪いことしてたいんだけど
お腹が壊すのは嫌でしょうに
だからなんですよ 道徳っていうのはそこを分かれば守るべきものであると
不道徳っていうのはものすごい避けるべきものであるとわかるんです
人殺しとはあかんっていうのはそういうわけなんです
別に人殺しでは思うんじゃなくて
あなた病気やと 怒りがもう脱線したんだと
だから仏教は別に人が人を殺したって
あの人を憎しみってことしないんです
とにかくもう叱って怒鳴って
もうもう直してもらおうと
これからでもいい人間になろうというふうに
まあ袖を通してするんです
ユダヤ教やらね イスラム教やらね
他の文化的な思考やらね
まあ殴ったら殴れとかね
殺したら殺せとかね  100万盗まれたら相手の 100万盗んだってでもそれは盗みじゃありませんよとかいう風な
この教えるのは道徳知らないんだからなんです
だからイエス様言ってはもうほっぺた殴ったらもうもう一つもあげちゃえというのは正しいんです
左殴ったらじゃあ右も出せ
というのはいくらか正しいんです
憎むなよということだからね
怒るなよって意味だからね
仏教はそういうことはしない
あのね あなたに私は何にも悪いことしてないのに
あんた人を殴るんだと
まああんたアホじゃないかと
そんなことしちゃうとひどい目にあいますよという物語でも教えてあげるんです
昔々はとあります そういう物語とか
で そういうわけで不道徳は禁物になるんです
はい 次に行きます 精神病に気づかない
人間というのは 不道徳というのは精神病ということに気づかないんですよ
人の行動について大げさに話す
だってそうでしょう 何々さんが 3人殺したんでは？なんてことですか
なんで 14歳の女の子はもう友達を殺したんでしょうか
なんででしょうかとか
何時間もマスコミはもう公の電波を使って
またお金もねじ金儲かるんだから
あれよく大げさに喋るんですよ
間違いについて原因も勘が考慮する
それだけじゃなくてね
あ こういう原因ではないか
あの女の子はあまりにも一人で生活していたんだからではないかとか
もうちょっと仲良くした方が良かったんではないかと
今更遅いんだけど あの神戸の少年がもうまだ 2
3人殺しちゃってるでしょうし
やっぱりもうそれは親があまり子供のことを気にしなかったんだからではないかとかね
親はもうちょっと先に気づいておいた方が良かったんではないかとかね
子供の異常にとかね 今更そんなこと言ったって遅いのは遅いですけどね
しかし 誰も最初 的な解決を見出せない
この評論家やら道徳の専門家やら
ガチャガチャガチャガチャ言うんだけど
ではどうすればいいかということは誰も持ってないんです
親のせい 虐待のせい 社会のせい
学校のせいなどが言いますが
この心の中の問題には全くも気づかない
これ 誰のせいでもないんですよ
この子の個人の心にある病気のせいなんです
はい 次に行きます あまり難しくないでしょう
悪の原因として悪行為が起こり得る条件を言い出す
彼らが言っているのは悪の原因じゃないんです
条件なんです 例えば親に虐待されると
まあ子供は人を虐待する
いじめる条件ができてるんです
あまり気にしない 殴ったって
だって自分も殴られてきたんだからね
まあそれくらいへっちゃらと思うんです
あれは原因じゃないんです
条件です だからこの倫理学者は条件勘違いしています
条件原因だと 親に虐待されても
すべての人が悪くならない
親のしつけがしつけが悪くても
すべての人が悪人にはならないでしょう
学校で大失敗しても 皆無知無学になるわけではないでしょうに
学校でも点数はものすごいすごい低いのにノーベル賞を取った人もいるでしょうに
いくらでもいますよ あのアメリカ有名のあの人もそうでしょうしね
何だったっけ 発明ばっかりやっていたりとか
頭が悪くて 学校では全然立場がなくて
でもいろいろ だからあんなのは条件であって原因じゃない
もし原因であるならば
親に虐待される子は必ずしも悪人にならなくちゃいけないんです
原因だったら まあ例えば毒
もう毒ありますね あの
何て言いますか サイナイ
サイナイは日本語で何て言いますか
青酸カリ  青酸カリ で 青酸カリ飲んだ
猛毒でしょ？飲んだら死ぬ
もう決まってます なぜならば
これは原因です 条件は違いますよ
だからこの道徳の人々は条件が原因だと言うんです
親に虐待されたことは条件であって
悪人になりやすくなっただけ
もともと悪人なんです
それで私ももともと悪人なんです
しかし 親にすごく大事にされちゃって
可愛がってもらって お母さんが悲しいんだからね
悪いことだけするなと言うと
なんとなく悪いことしない気分になるだけ
お母ちゃんがかわいそうだってことも
だからあれが条件なんですよ
条件だけど原因じゃないんです
はい 次に行きます 悪の原因として条件を述べるということで
国民多数が戦争に賛成しても平和を好む人もいる
だからまあこれってなんかわからないんですね
だからこのみんな戦争賛成やと言っても
みんなそうじゃないでしょうに
私は反対という人いるんだから
世の中 金がないから 貧乏だからみんな泥棒するわけではありませんでしょう
時々平気で言うで泥棒したのは
あれが貧乏だからとか
でも結構貧乏な人いるで全然泥棒はしない
金持ちも金持ちもありあふれ
ありあふれ ありあふれている人も強盗するんですよ
金持ちも強盗するでしょう
皆様大好きな仏様 結局あれ強盗ですよ
ある意味っていうのは
だからありあふれた原因でも強盗する時もあります
これらは悪行為を引き起こす条件だけなのです
悪の原因ではありません
だからもうまあ 泥棒の始まりは嘘やというのは
それは別な意味なんですけど
それも条件ちゃ言ってるでしょう
嘘が泥棒やと言ってないでしょうに
泥棒の始まりは嘘やと
仏教はすべての悪の始まりは嘘やと言っています
泥棒だけじゃないんです
嘘を言う人にはできない悪がないんだと
嘘言う勇気あれば まあそれは流れのことで言って
条件ということで 悪の原因じゃないんです
空き巣に入る人はみんな仕事がなくて
食い物がなくて空き巣に入るわけじゃないでしょ
だってサラリーマンも空き巣に入る時あるでしょう
ああいうのは条件 はい
次 早く終わらないと えーと
条件だけでは解決はない
条件を述べただけで解決ではありませんよ
世界の倫理専門家は条件
しか知らないのです だから悪行為をした人も
それは条件のせいにしてしまう
つなげて読んでほしいんですね
世の中の倫理専門家は条件ばっか言うでしょう
そこで私は悪いことをする
悪いことしたら私は私にみんな説教するでしょ
で 説教すると条件言うでしょ
あ あなたは虐待されてそう育てられたんだからねとかね
それで人殺した自分も
やっぱり私は母親に大事にされなかったんだから
悪人になったんだぞと言うんです
親に愛されなかったから
虐待されたから なんか間違いありますね
虐待されたからこのような人間になったと
とにかく条件言っちゃうとどうなるかというと
悪を正当化するんですよ
見てください 世の中はどれほど間違っているのかと
みんな条件もうペラペラペラ伸びてますよ
環境が悪かった 学校の環境悪かった
先生に恵まれなかった
親のしつけが悪かった
親にいじめられた 親に虐待された
親に愛されなかった そういうことで
その子供たちは この現代人はろくでもない人間になったというと
あの馬鹿どもたち知らないのは自分たちが悪を正当化しているんです
だから仏教を知った方がいいんですよ
とんでもないことになるんです
このように言う人は自分が悪くないと言い張ってるんです
結局は自分が悪くないと言い張ってるんです
悪くないから直す必要もないでしょう
だから直す必要なくなっちゃうんです
はい 次いきます カウンセラーも条件だけを見て
クライエントが正しい仕方なく間違いを犯したと理解している
これは誤解ですけど で
カウンセラーのところに行ったら
大体犯罪 特に未成年の人々犯罪を起こしちゃうとカウンセリング合わせるでしょうに会わせてはいけないんですよ
もうとんでもないことになるんだ
だって我々みたいな宗教家にはもう必ず禁止でしょ
でもその代わりに宗教も道徳もひとかけらもないカウンセラーとかなんとかという何か資格だけ取ってる人々がいて
偉そうに教えたりするでしょう
とんでもないことなんです
で それでカウンセリングする側も
あ あなた君はね まあいろいろ学校でいじめられたんだからね
気持ちは分かりますよと
腹が立った気持ちはよく分かります
せいとかするんですよ
互いに認め合っていい気にはなるが
答えはそれ答えですかね
人生は取り戻せないから
虐待を受けて育てられた人はもう一度優しい親に育ててもらうのでしょうかね
そんな条件聞いたって
もう遅い 君はね 親に虐待されたんだからね
気持ちわかりますよ じゃあどうやれば？じゃあもっと優しい親に育ててもらうとか
何言うんですかね そんなのは道徳じゃないんですよ
もう取り戻せないんだから
人生は だから虐待されたら虐待されたでいいんじゃないんですかね
私はそういう人の だからあなたはそれをどうやって受け止めているのかと
バカじゃないかと 親に虐待されたらしっかりした人間になるでしょうと
親に負けない人間になることで
なんでお前バカじゃないかと
私はそう言うんです もう二度と来るなよと
そんな考え方のに 自分の間違いを他人に言うなよと
受け方が間違ってるんだと
親に殴られても親に殴られない
隣のじじいに殴られたと思うんですかと
何考えてるんですかと
あなたとんでもないことすると親に殴られてよかったんじゃないんですかと
もし誰か知らない人に殴られたらどうなるんですかと
私のカウンセリングはそういうやり方なんです
全然親切に見えません
しかし それが親切なんです
期待しなかった答えだから
相手がびっくりしちゃって
それで直すんです 言ってることは事実だから逆らえないでしょ
騙してないんだから人を
だから私はあくまであなたのせいだと
親が学校に行くなよと言ったら
バカみたいに学校に行ってなかったら自分のせいでしょうに
親に隠れておばさんの家にでも逃げ
逃げ込んで学校に行けばいいでしょうに
行きたければ あるいは知らない人にでもお願いして
私はこういう状態でなんとかもう家に泊まってくださいと
そうするとみんなもう子供は親切だからね
この子本当にいい子でしょうと
勉強したがってるんだと
それにしてはうちの子はとかね
じゃあ君 家に泊まってもいいやと
なぜならば この人は真面目に勉強するんだから
うちの子ももしかするとその気になるかもしれませんということで
もう赤の他人でも助けてくれますよ
だから親のせいにするんじゃない
人のせいにするんじゃないっていうのは僕の立場なんです
で あるいは親に対して憎しみを爆発するのかと
親に対して憎しみを爆発しても答えじゃないで
親殺したっても 虐待された自分が何か答えが見つかるんでないでしょ
しかし 西洋心理学はその 2番目の選択するんですよ
怒りを話せと もう枕とかなんとか持ってきて
もう思い出させて思い出させて
それで殴った親だと思ってくださいと
だから小さい時に殴られなかったら今殴れとかね
さらに精神的な病気にするんです
怒りをもともと再現させちゃって
仏教のやり方はものすごい違うんです
悪を正当化しながら悪を足すというありえない無茶なやり方は釈迦の教えにはありません
悪を正当化しながら悪を足すという
こんな無茶できない はい
次 もう早く終わります
それで自覚なき悪 才能
幸福 幸福 成功 希望 安らぎを破壊する心理的な原因が常に心にある
自覚はないんですけどね
あの14はぐるぐる回しながら心にあるんです
それは隠れてるわけではありません
ただ 条件がない限り実らないだけ
皆様に怒りがないわけじゃないんです
条件がないんだから 怒りはむき出してないだけなんです
欲は全くないわけじゃないんです
その条件がないんだからむき出しになってないだけで
条件に条件そろったらパーッと現れてきます
だからいつでも心の中で持っているんです
悪の原因は えーと精神病に侵されることは人が望まない
完全に健康な精神を築くことが真の道徳倫理だと理解することは釈尊の通説です
だから別にもう不道徳やめようとか何とか言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
完全な健康な精神状態にします
健康いいでしょ 肉体も健康でいいでしょ
だったら心も健康で悪くないでしょうに
だから 健康なんです 答えは
なぜ不道徳は悪いのかというと
答えはあれは精神の健康ではありませんだから
精神病気だからなんです
そういうポイントで人殺してはならないし
嘘言ってはならないし
だって自分が病気でしょうに
だからじゃあ急ぎに解説します
これで終わります えーと
ブッダの道徳論は世間一般の思考ではありません
ブッダも誰か誰が言ってるものを同じことを繰り返したわけじゃないでしょ
もうわかるでしょ まるっきり新しい発見なんです
人間の悪行為 癖の 悪行為癖
悪行為するということは癖なんですね
その原因を追求する 自分の病を治ること
楽になる道 成功の道 幸福への道
勝利への道だと理解できる人が
倫理道徳はうるさいものだと思わない
倫理道徳っていうのは成功の道
幸福の道 安らぎの道 希望叶う道
努力実る道ですよ だから
松茸でご飯食べるのはすごい気分はいいもので
青酸カリを飲むのはもう死ぬもので
それをわかったらね みんな松茸ご飯にするとするでしょうに
いえ 私は青酸カリが美味しいやと思わないでしょうに
だからそれでブッダが道徳なんです
すっごい厳しく もうもう文句言えないように設定して言うんです
しかし 社会 世界 親 教師
宗教が語る道徳倫理は本当にうるさいんです
そこまで言っても私も認めます
うるさいんですよ もうわかってもないくせに言うんだから
だから言いたいのは 社会の道徳に逆らってもどうったことはない
宗教の道徳に逆らってもどうったことはない
親言うことに逆らっても何のこともないんです
学校の先生言うことに逆らっても何のこともないんです
それで不幸になるってわけじゃないんです
本人は道徳を知らないんだから
しかし 本物の不道徳は
自分の心に入っている病気の原因なんです
それが一歩間違えば明らかな精神病気になるんだから
ものすごい気をつけなくちゃいけないのはあの十四項目なんです
それにさえ気をつけていれば
親に逆らっても大丈夫
幸福になります 学校の先生に無茶逆らっても
あの十四に気をつければもう完璧にうまくいくんです
だから仏教は腰抜けの人は育ちません
逆らう時は逆らうんです
先生に言いたい時は言っちゃうんです
しかし 道徳は犯しません
だから仏教の世界では
もう生徒が先生に怒鳴っても
先生はなるほどと考えますよ
真面目に 生徒をいじめようとしないんです
自分でも分かっていないのに
分かってないのに 実行しないのに
相手に押し付けようとしているだけです
それはもう世間の道徳なんですね
自分たちでも分かってないんですけど
相手に押し付けようとする
だから質問しないと私は言うんですよ
親が嘘を言うなよと子供に言っても
子供がもう悪い悪ガキで
なんで嘘言ったら悪いの？と聞いたこと
お母さんに答えがないんだから
お母さんも分かってないということになるんです
だから その質問に答えられるのはお釈迦様だけになってます
なぜならば 今までいろんな哲学者
心理学者 いろんな人が本やらいろんなことを書いてますけど
道徳は解明できてないんです
宗教の本もいくらでもありますけど
道徳というのはそれほど命に厳密に関わりあるものだと誰も説明できてないんです
はい まあそれで終了だと思います
ではどうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました